اليكم مشاهدينا هذا الخبر الذي ربما يغير
نظرتكم في الاستعداد للسفر والذي قد
يستغرق منكم ايضا وقتا طويلا بطل الخبر
جيمي ماكدونالدز الذي سجل رقما قياسيا
جديدا بزيارته عجائب الدنيا السبع في اقل
من سبعه ايام
هذا الرحاله البريطاني بدا رحلته في سور
الصين العظيم وانتهى به المشوار في مدينه
توقف جميع عند تاج محل في الهند والبتراء
في الاردن مرورا طبعا في البرازيل وبيرو
كل هذا كان مستخدما ويستخدم وسائل النقل
الجماعي في رحلته التي قطع فيها 37 الف
كيلو متر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات